j'espère qu'un jour je recueillir autour
de ce brillant donc le modèle réduit a
été offert en souvenir la partie la plus
âgée de la beauté d'un peu mieux mais
si mr d'ego les plaisirs de boussoufa
c'est un très grand honneur pour nous
d'être reçu dans cette magnifique
résidence les sublimes comme votre
grande nation comme l'image aussi que
nous avons de votre grande nation et je
remercie infiniment le président poutine
pour sont ces différentes attention et
c'est cadeau je l'aurais la fierté de
les transmettre à mon père qui
effectivement célèbre ses 100 ans demain
l'un des
scénarios celui de soldat sienne avec le
papa merci maman
et nous formons des voeux de bonne santé
de prospérité pour le président poutine
et tout le peuple russe merci beaucoup
de civils suzuka